let's try Josiah from North Carolina
Josiah welcome to the program what's
going on DPAC how are you doing well
so obviously big news from Wisconsin
um as you heard that Republicans in
Wisconsin are already at least a few of
them talking about impeaching Justice
protest say which
uh I did not hear that for what reason
uh well I mean uh right now they're just
kind of forecasting it they would come
up with grounds that she's not going to
uh not going to uh abide by her oath
she's not going to support Wisconsin law
right and the the idea is just you know
throw anything at her that sticks would
you be surprised if they do that if they
actually impeach her or if they try to
try to oh uh no it would not surprise me
but you know oftentimes it's sort of
like Marjorie Taylor green has tried to
impeach Joe Biden but it doesn't even
like get started so you know the word
try is doing a lot of heavy work there
you know what I mean
the the bulk of my question concerns
actually my state North Carolina I don't
know if you heard this but one of our
state representatives her name is Trisha
cotham just this morning she formally
announced that she was switching from
the Democratic party to the Republican
Party even though she ran as a democrat
in November and was just sworn in in
January the first my first question is
do you consider this fraudulent
so I think the problem with fraudulent
or unethical is can you prove that this
was her intent at the time obviously
you're allowed to switch party but if
there was uh I I think in order to
demonstrate that it's fraudulent you
would have to demonstrate that this was
part of a plan all the way from the
beginning I don't know whether you can
demonstrate that or not if you could I
think it would certainly be fraudulent
that's fair that's fair and certainly I
agree to like a legal scrutiny I I would
not I would not make the case that uh
there's a compelling case to be made
that you could prove it to a legal
satisfaction but yeah I guess she you
know she ran as a progressive Democrat
in Mecklenburg County which is a really
blue District of North Carolina it's
just right out so it's part of Charlotte
yeah and it seems to me pretty sketched
that in three months she's switching
parties switching platforms and there's
no uh run off or recall like provision
there would you support in the event
that um a politician switches parties
and switches platforms and things like
that that it triggers some sort of
recall or runoff provision that's really
tough I I would I'm open to voters
deciding whether they want a recall I
don't know about automatically doing it
and here's the difficulty people do
change positions during the time that
they're in office so then you would have
to say well if you change positions
enough or if you change party my view is
you the voters should be able to gather
signatures if they want to recall
someone but It ultimately has to be up
to the voters I'm not going to say
anytime you change party you should be
immediately there should be a recall
election that seems like too much but
you should be subject to a recall
yeah I guess it's it's kind of it's the
reason I'm so salty about it is because
her doing so has given Republicans in
North Carolina a veto proof majority we
were one seat away from it and Governor
Cooper was kind of you know he's a
Democrat he was getting by by the skin
of his teeth and now that she switched
parties it's a it's a veto proof
majority it's ugly it's ugly no doubt I
understand that and and I mean listen
the voters can consider that in
determining whether they would want to
have a recall election
no yeah I agree as far as I know I don't
think that it even allows like a recall
election I agree that you're probably
right that an auto recall is probably
too cumbersome but there at least should
be a provision that if enough of her
constituents like I think in the event
of um George Santos right the guy the
serial liar at a North Carolina 80
percent of New York New York New York oh
yeah yeah sorry I'm a North Carolina
brand at the moment but yeah New York 80
of his constituents want him to resign
right and as far as I know there's no
recall provision there like even if
enough of his constituents demand his
resignation he's he's allowed to serve
the remainder of his terms yeah not
every place has recall Provisions but
very very interesting situation there in
North Carolina I appreciate you telling
us about it I appreciate that David have
a good one all right there goes Josiah
and that'll do it for calls today we'll
take a quick break and then get to your
emails and your tweets and your comments
and the entire thing